who would have thought we'd be standing
here with metallica today the band that
would punch each other in the face and
number right right like like lars one
time james hit you in the face because
uh he didn't like the way you perform i
mean
jesus that's right
talk about the good old days by the way
when he punches you in the face when
james punches you in the face is can he
throw a punch or is it really not that
bad
oh god
it um uh
i let's put it this way this will answer
your question
we were playing uh i think just down the
street from here we're at the troubadour
or i think it was a troubadour right it
was the first show
uh where we ever
at least in our minds got an encore yeah
we were we were six nine months into our
career
we got an encore
so we're standing off stage
discussing what song to play and then
let's just say there was a differences
of opinion so i said i suggested a song
that started with drums so
james suggested something else
we went back up on stage and i started
the song that started with drums
and um and so when i we came off uh i
got a uh
the slight punch in the uh in the
stomach
uh i did
stand up for the rest of the night
however i think for for balance
i will say that uh throughout the rest
of the 80s uh
james
helped me in many situations but when i
uh
i i had a little bit of a of a big mouth
and and could definitely throw the best
smart ass comments back to people and
there were a couple times when the beer
and the good times were flowing where i
would say the wrong thing to the wrong
people but still they were really funny
and 30 years later
they still as sound bites you know
elicit chuckles when you tell the story
but james was always there as my big
brother
uh he had your back
i would usually just run
you know i just [ __ ] take off but
then james would clean it up for me and
throw a few punches at some of these
other guys james how did you know how to
fight so well uh was this a something
taught or you just had a lot of fights
in your
life
i don't know how to fight at all i i
really don't i just have attitude fueled
by yeah i started the mouth and i had
the doctor know yeah it was right it was
quite a deadly combination punch is
thrown right by jagermeister yeah it was
it was bad wouldn't you worry about your
hands though i mean as a guitar player
no hell no you don't care about anything
man don't think about that